it may just be 24 hours but Joe Biden is
hoping he's accomplished a lot from his
first official visit to Canada since
winning the White House at a time when
new alliances are being forged elsewhere
this was about showing one of the oldest
links in the world is still strong both
sides are putting the best spin they can
on the visit which brought a
face-to-face sit down and an address to
the Canadian Parliament
Americans and Canadians are two people
two countries in my view sharing one
heart but there are tensions not least
at the border crossings from America
into Canada are now at historically high
levels one point between New York State
and Quebec a hot spot even in Winter now
both countries have agreed they can turn
away would-be Asylum seekers in exchange
Canada will accept 15 000 more Central
and South American migrants through
legal channels our border is no longer
just the place where we meet each other
place where we will meet the moment the
two leaders also addressed issues like
climate change the war in Ukraine and
the growing threat from China the Spy
balloon that flew over America recently
before being shot down crossed Canadian
airspace suspending more on defense has
become a priority as is paying attention
to existing allies we have
you know uh significantly expanded our
alliances I haven't seen that happen
with China and or Russia or anybody else
in the world we're in a situation in the
United States where NATO is stronger
we're all together the G7
the quad the uh asean uh Japan and Korea
let's see please
When Donald Trump visited Canada in 2018
he tweeted out an attack on the Prime
Minister after he left the warm smiles
and firm handshakes this time around
suggest relations between the two
countries are better but they still have
issues that haven't disappeared Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera